Ngay Mình Sau Thang Chính, là năng sống phản đối trong nước,
đó cũng tìm ra tăng trước chuyện trị còn sự quyền mồ lớn của Israel nhằm đánh triển thành phố gà ra.
Hăng nghiên ngồi Israel trong nỏ còn nhiều cụ con tín và thân nhân đã biểu tình trước dinh thủ đường 20 xe lên.
Hỏ lống ngại chuyên dịch sẽ khiến số 8 ta còn tín còn sống thiệt mạng,
và kêu vọt chính phủ sớm đặt tỏ thật lịch nằm bánh.
Nếu tổ chức nhân quyền tại Israel thầm chỉ lên an lạnh sơ tảng của con đối là phi pháp,
có thể cầu thành tối á chuyên tranh,
một số quản trước an các cao trong đò của cả thầm yếu trưởng ở nhà dạm viên tiếp tục phản đối kể hoạt đánh triển thành phố gà ra.
Bối thúc chính phủ tìm dạy pháp chào đổi con tín trên bình diện có thể,
ai cập cảnh bảo chung đồng đứng trên bờ hỗt lạm mới giò hành vi lượng lịch Israel trong khi vô tế văn nhà phí li pê sấu và đầy là cuộc khủ thằng nhìn đạo không thể chứ lịch nổi.
Lì mình cho ông hẳn định trên sích mộ bình sẽ gây thêm thương vong và phá huy,
đồng thời tuyên bố sơm của bệnh pháp gây sự gái và tèa viết bất chấp là sảo chí chết.
Thủ tương Israel bất yêu cầu đây mắt sơ tảng ở Perc Stin để gồn đổi mở đường tên bất hình phủ gà ra.
Theo ngồi tình E-Tap Perc Stin chỉ giữa trong ai mề sảo thằng chiến,
các cuộc tấn công đã khiến hàng trục người chết và hàng trăm người bị thương nhiều nạn nhân bất mắc két rồi đồng đường á.